Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans cette émission
spéciale "Etat de santé" consacrée
au médecin de famille,
une espèce en voie de disparition.
Ce médecin de famille
qu'on consultait toute sa vie
et qu'on pouvait parfois déranger
nuit et jour,
qui connaissait toute la famille,
eh bien, il n'existe presque plus.
Pourquoi ?
On va essayer
de le comprendre
avec tous nos invités.
Et puis,
quel modèle va remplacer
ce médecin de famille
qu'on ne verra bientôt
que dans les films
et les livres ?
On va en parler avec vous,
Dr Marine Crest.
Merci d'être avec nous.
Vous êtes médecin généraliste
à Marseille, vous avez fondé
l'association Guérir en mer,
vous nous direz,
mais on a compris l'idée,
qui accompagne
les soignants victimes de burn-out.
Vous en avez eu un,
mais pendant vos études,
et maintenant, vous aidez
les médecins, jeunes ou non,
peut-être, à combiner
la vie professionnelle
avec la vie personnelle.
Vous avez été chargée
par le ministère de la Santé,
en mars 2023
de rédiger un rapport
sur la santé des soignants.
Frédéric Valletoux,
député Horizons de Seine-et-Marne,
rapporteur de la proposition
de loi sur l'accès
aux soins qui a été
adoptée en 1re lecture au Sénat.
Elle est ressortie un peu amendée,
pour ne pas dire beaucoup,
mais vous nous direz
quelles sont vos propositions,
précisément, pour faire muter
ce métier de médecin
que vous connaissez
parfaitement bien.
Arnaud Bontemps,
merci d'être là.
Vous avez été en charge
de l'organisation territoriale
des soins à la CPAM
de Seine-Saint-Denis,
en pleine crise du Covid.
Alors, vous avez dû voir
ce que c'est
que la santé sous tension.
Vous avez cofondé le collectif
Nos services publics
pour mettre la question du service
public au coeur du débat politique.
Merci, Maria Roubtsova,
d'être ici.
Economiste, chargée de mission
santé à l'UFC-Que Choisir,
vous avez participé
à l'écriture de rapports
sur les déserts médicaux.
Et enfin, Dr Hamon,
Dr Hamon,
on vous connaît bien.
Vous avez 50 ans d'exercice.
Bel anniversaire !
50 ans de médecine générale
au sein de votre cabinet
à Clamart,
en région parisienne.
Egalement président d'honneur
de la Fédération
des médecins de France,
vous portez depuis longtemps
la parole syndicale
des médecins généralistes.
Vous continuez de consulter ?
-Je consulte à temps plein,
dans un groupe
de cinq médecins généralistes
qui a été créé en 52,
à l'époque où l'Ordre
des médecins considérait
que ce n'était pas bien
de se regrouper.
C'était un médecin...
-On y reviendra tout à l'heure,
mais c'est intéressant.
Dr Crest,
le médecin de famille a disparu.
Ca vous parle, vous,
le médecin de famille ou,
bon, c'est ça le Moyen Age ?
-Moi, je ne suis
ni trop jeune, ni trop vieille.
Je représente
la tranche d'âge intermédiaire
et la grande population
des femmes médecins,
car ce sont des métiers
qui sont très féminisés.
Il y a 10 ans,
je faisais une émission
dont le titre était
"Enquête de santé:
"la fin du médecin de famille".
C'était une des 1res émissions,
il y a 10 ans.
Je suis toujours médecin généraliste
et un médecin de famille.
Si la question est : "Il n'y a plus
de médecin de famille ?",
la réponse est : il y en a.
Mais c'est pas ceux
qui étaient là avant
et ce n'est pas ceux
qui seront là demain.
C'est un métier
en cours d'évolution.
On est à un changement
qui est en train de se construire
avec les différents acteurs.
La différence avec avant,
c'est que, dans ces acteurs-là
il y les médecins, les soignants,
mais aussi les patients
et les générations qui évoluent.
J'ai du mal, parfois,
à comprendre des confrères
qui sont un tout petit peu
plus jeunes ou un peu plus âgés.
Chacun intègre sa profession
dans son quotidien
de façon différente,
avec des nécessités et des besoins
qui évoluent avec ceux
de la société.
Ca change.
-Un médecin de famille,
c'était en général un homme
Alors moi, je dis que c'est
un modèle en voie de disparition.
Il s'est féminisé,
comme vous l'avez souligné
dès le début.
Alors, les médecins
ne sont rien sans les patients.
Si c'est compliqué
d'être médecin aujourd'hui,
ça l'est aussi
d'être patient.
Quel est le ratio,
le nombre de médecins
généralistes, aujourd'hui,
qui disent non
à de nouveaux patients ?
-Alors aujourd'hui,
près de la moitié des médecins
généralistes refusent
les nouveaux patients.
C'est compliqué de trouver
un médecin traitant,
sachant que des annonces
ont été faites
par les autorités cette année
pour dire qu'on allait trouver
des médecins traitants
aux patients en affections
de longue durée.
La première chose qu'a faite
la Sécurité sociale a été d'écrire
aux patients sans médecin,
comme si c'était à eux
de se débrouiller,
alors que les patients
sont aujourd'hui
dans un problème systémique
de pénurie,
donc ce n'est pas souvent...
Souvent, ce n'est pas faute
de volonté du patient,
c'est faute d'accessibilité,
selon où on habite,
selon si les médecins
sont proches
de leur départ en retraite,
s'ils ont déjà
beaucoup de patientèle.
Vous avez déjà résumé
ou cité quelques causes, évidemment,
de la démographie médicale
en grande pénurie.
On s'arrête quelques instants
pour un petit point d'histoire.
Pourquoi les généralistes sont-ils
de moins en moins nombreux ?
Explication de texte.
-En France, 1 personne sur 3
vit dans un désert médical.
6 millions de personnes
n'ont pas de médecin traitant,
et leur recherche
pourrait bien durer,
car la pénurie a empiré
ces dernières années.
La densité de médecins généralistes
est passée de 153
pour 100 000 habitants en 2012
à 140 pour 100 000 en 2021.
Pourquoi ?
Principalement
parce que nous ne formons
pas assez de médecins,
et cela remonte aux années 70.
A cette époque,
les cabinets médicaux
poussaient comme des champignons
et les bancs des facs de médecine
étaient remplis
de futurs généralistes.
Mais c'est aussi à cette époque
qu'on a découvert
le trou de la Sécu.
Pour le combler, et sous l'influence
des médecins libéraux,
le gouvernement a choisi
de limiter les dépenses
en limitant le nombre de médecins.
Le numerus clausus faisait
son apparition.
De 8500 places offertes
aux étudiants en 1977,
on est descendus
jusqu'à 3500 admissions en 1993.
Le nombre de nouveaux médecins
a drastiquement baissé,
et dans le même temps,
la demande de soins, elle,
a augmenté
car la population vieillit.
Les baby-boomers nés
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale
ont atteint le troisième âge
dans les années 2010.
On parle de papy-boom.
Pour ne rien arranger,
les généralistes, eux aussi,
vieillissent comme tout le monde :
près de 50 %
des médecins inscrits à l'Ordre
ont plus de 60 ans.
Ainsi, depuis 2020, il y a davantage
de départs à la retraite
que de nouveaux arrivants.
Heureusement, le numerus clausus
a augmenté au début des années 2000.
En 2020, il a été remplacé
par un numerus apertus,
c'est-à-dire un quota minimum
de places
fixé par les facs de médecine
en fonction
des besoins du territoire.
Mais ces décisions
ne devraient porter leurs fruits
qu'à partir de 2030.
-Si on comprend bien,
Arnaud Bontemps, en 2030,
on essaie de voir
ce qui peut nous donner
un peu d'espoir,
en 2030,
ce sera le pic de la pénurie
de médecins liée
à cette logique du numérus clausus.
On commencera à avoir un peu moins
de pénurie à partir de 2030 ?
-Ca, ce serait faire abstraction
de l'évolution continue,
dans le même temps,
des besoins de santé.
Le reportage mentionnait la question
du vieillissement de la population.
Ces 10 dernières années,
c'est 12 % de plus de 75 ans en plus
dans la population.
Dans le même temps, ce qui est
encore plus frappant,
c'est l'évolution
du nombre des affections
longue durée, les maladies
chroniques et les cancers.
Ces 10 dernières années,
c'est +30 %.
Aujourd'hui, c'est 1 patient sur 6.
C'est ça, l'enjeu auquel
il faut qu'on réponde.
C'est pour ça qu'il y a une crise
du système de santé aujourd'hui,
en particulier
la médecine de ville :
c'est qu'on a un système qui a été
inchangé dans ses modalités,
alors que les évolutions
pathologiques
sont épidémiologiques
et très fortes.
En effet, le modèle
d'un professionnel de santé
qui serait un médecin isolé
ne correspond plus
à la prise en charge
des patients chroniques
qui nécessite un travail en équipe
entre différentes professions.
C'est ça qu'il faut
que notre modèle
arrive à inciter.
-Vous direz
quelles sont les solutions
qu'on peut mettre en place,
évidemment au bénéfice de tous.
Il y a moins de médecins
et un problème de répartition.
Regardez cette carte.
Vous allez regarder attentivement.
Toute cette carte de France
est en fait mitée
par des petits points blancs.
C'est là où il y a pratiquement
aucun ou presque aucun médecin.
Ensuite, vous voyez que,
plus c'est foncé,
plus il y a de médecins disponibles
au service des patients.
On voit bien que le sud,
au sens large,
est assez bien doté,
avec les parties littorales,
où il y a quand même, là,
une démographie assez positive,
et puis,
plus on monte vers le nord,
et surtout autour de la capitale
ainsi que le centre de la France,
eh bien là, il y a une pénurie
de médecins caractérisée.
Je voudrais qu'on aille
tout de suite dans la Creuse.
C'est un des départements
les moins dotés.
La Creuse, à Châtelus-Malvaleix,
écoutez ce couple de médecins,
66 et 64 ans.
Il voudrait, ce couple de médecins,
prendre sa retraite.
Il ne trouve pas
de successeurs.
Vous entendrez, dans la foulée,
un patient, évidemment,
qui est pénalisé.
-On a mis des annonces
un peu partout
et je pense qu'on n'est pas
les seuls
à chercher.
Ca fait 36 ans que je suis là,
que je connais les familles
depuis deux-trois générations,
donc ce sont plus des amis
que des patients,
donc c'est très difficile
de les laisser tomber.
On a soigné les parents,
les enfants,
maintenant, on soigne
les petits-enfants.
Ca fait un peu mal au coeur, quoi.
Il y a des gens
qui ne seront plus suivis,
qui vont arrêter leur traitement.
Ca va être vraiment dramatique,
je pense, oui.
J'ai proposé à la commune
de travailler deux jours par semaine
comme salarié avec ma femme
pour essayer de dépanner un peu
en attendant de trouver
un successeur.
-Ca m'inquiète
parce qu'il va falloir
retrouver un médecin,
et les médecins,
ils sont surchargés.
Le désert médical,
c'est de pire en pire.
Je sais pas où on va aller
comme ça, où on va...
Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ?
"Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ?"
Il s'agit de trouver des réponses.
Frédéric Valletoux,
vous avez présenté
une proposition de loi,
soumis une proposition de loi
au Sénat,
avec un certain nombre
de mesures que vous préconisez.
Tout de suite,
je pose la question qui fâche,
on tourne autour
depuis des années.
D'abord, la coercition,
l'obligation faite aux médecins,
par exemple,
à la sortie de leurs études,
de s'installer là où les patients
en ont besoin,
vous n'y êtes pas favorable ?
-Je n'y suis pas favorable
dans la période actuelle.
Je n'y suis pas favorable
quand on a si peu de médecins
chaque année,
vous donniez les chiffres,
à répartir
là où il y a des besoins.
Par contre, que, dans l'avenir,
dans les années qui redeviendront,
"fastes", c'est peut-être
un grand mot,
en tout cas meilleures,
dans les années 30-32-35,
quand effectivement plus de jeunes
auront été formés,
qu'il y ait un système qui veille
à ne pas reproduire
les erreurs du passé
de concentration
et de juste répartition.
-Par quels moyens ?
-C'est à la profession
d'y réfléchir.
Nous, les parlementaires,
on peut avoir des idées,
mais beaucoup de professions
se sont prises par la main
et ont imaginé des systèmes,
les pharmaciens,
ils ont imaginé d'eux-mêmes
des systèmes
pour répondre
à l'intérêt général
et aux besoins des Français.
On pourrait attendre
effectivement que,
dans les années qui nous éloignent
de cette époque
de 2035 que j'évoquais,
on puisse voir émerger
des propositions
pour qu'on dise :
"On ne va pas reproduire
ce qu'on a vécu par le passé."
Là, on parle des généralistes,
mais pour les spécialistes,
c'est encore pire.
La concentration des spécialistes,
c'est encore pire
que la question des généralistes.
Donc voilà,
c'est un système à inventer.
Pour l'instant,
ce n'est pas le sujet.
La coercition,
on sait que malheureusement,
c'est un sujet qui fâche.
Si cette profession doit évoluer,
et elle doit évoluer,
il faut emmener avec nous
les médecins.
-Si je comprends bien,
pas de coercition
dans un système hyper tendu où,
pour l'instant,
il y a un manque criant
de médecins disponibles.
-Répartir la rareté
ne rendra personne riche.
-Pour éclairer nos débats,
comparons-nous aux autres.
Regardez cette carte
qu'on a préparée, justement,
pour vous montrer
ce qui se passe ailleurs.
Aux Pays-Bas et en Belgique,
à l'instar de la France,
les médecins sont libres
de s'installer
où ils le souhaitent.
Il y a des mesures incitatives.
On va parler de l'Allemagne,
du Danemark et de la Norvège.
Là, il y a des mesures coercitives.
Par exemple au Danemark
et en Norvège,
pour prendre cet exemple,
les médecins généralistes
sont libéraux,
mais ils doivent
passer un contrat
avec les autorités locales
qui régulent la distribution
des cabinets sur le territoire.
En Grande-Bretagne et en Espagne,
les systèmes de santé sont publics,
les généralistes britanniques
sont installés, sont salariés
par la National Health Service,
NHS,
et donc leur installation
est parfaitement
régulée en fonction des besoins.
Les généralistes espagnols sont
salariés par les régions autonomes
et ce sont elles, les régions,
qui décident des effectifs
de médecins à former
et leur installation.
On voit bien
que des pays ont adopté
des systèmes
qui sont extrêmement différents.
La coercition,
est-ce que ça marche ?
Est-ce que ça permet à ces pays...
Est-ce que ça permet aux patients
d'être mieux soignés ?
Est-ce que ça permet
d'avoir des systèmes
qui fonctionnent mieux ?
-Il y a un rapport de la DREES,
le service statistique
du ministère de la Santé,
qui dit que les mesures coercitives,
combinées à d'autres mesures,
ont contribué, dans d'autres pays,
à améliorer l'accès aux soins.
Ce n'est pas la coercition seule,
mais ça peut être un élément
d'une politique qui marche bien.
Ils citent plusieurs exemples.
Mais par contre,
là où je ne partage pas l'analyse
de M. Valletoux, c'est que,
pour l'UFC-Que Choisir,
c'est parce que la pénurie
est intense
que c'est le moment de prendre
des mesures contraignantes
sur la liberté d'installation.
Ce que vous montriez
sur la démographie médicale,
avec le cas de la Creuse
du reportage,
est assez symptomatique.
On a montré, dans notre étude
sur l'accès aux soins,
que les départements
où les généralistes
sont les plus âgés
sont aussi les moins denses.
Dans la vague de départs
en retraite
qui n'en est qu'à ses débuts,
ça va être les départements
déjà les plus démunis
qui vont perdre
le plus de médecins
suite aux départs en retraite.
Pour nous, c'est pour ça
qu'il faut réguler maintenant
pour gérer la pénurie.
Ce que défend
l'UFC-Que Choisir,
ce n'est pas la coercition
au sens de prendre un jeune médecin
et de lui dire d'aller
dans la Creuse
mais de fermer l'installation
dans les zones les mieux dotées.
Par exemple, sur le littoral.
-Est-ce qu'il y a des zones
qui sont surdotées,
ou mieux dotées que les autres ?
-Il y a des zones
mieux dotées que les autres,
mais c'est quand il y a une pénurie
qu'on rationne,
donc pour nous,
il faut envoyer les patients
dans les zones...
-On déshabille Paul
pour habiller Jacques ?
Vous dites qu'on ne peut pas
faire autrement ?
-On va dans 10 ans de pénurie.
Il faut gérer les pénuries.
-Vous auriez accepté...
Dr Hamon, c'est à vous après.
Vous auriez accepté, docteur,
qu'on vous dise, à la fin
de vos études :
"Il vaudrait mieux aller là,
avec plus ou moins de..."
-"Vous allez ou voulez,
sauf les zones les mieux dotées."
-Voilà, merci d'avoir
reformulé la question.
-Il ne faut pas, à mon sens...
Les "il faut", "on doit",
"c'est la faute à"...
Quand vous faites médecine
ou une autre profession de soins,
au départ, vous le faites
plutôt par vocation et par élan.
Aujourd'hui, cet élan est
en train de se tarir.
Les jeunes n'ont pas envie
d'y aller car ils voient
ceux qui sont sur le terrain
qui arrêtent
et ils n'ont pas envie d'y aller.
Ils sont accompagnés
par des professionnels de santé
en souffrance.
Ils n'ont ni envie
d'y aller, ni envie de rester.
Obliger quelqu'un
avec cette contrainte,
ça ne marchera pas,
et encore moins en France :
ça ne correspond pas
à la personnalité du Français
ni à un besoin.
Si on vous force à faire
un métier là où vous n'avez pas
envie de le faire...
"On ne va pas y aller."
On m'aurait fait réfléchir
sur comment répondre à un besoin,
et que ça vienne de la part
des professionnels de santé...
Il faut comprendre
que c'est des femmes, des familles,
dans des zones sans attractivité
dans les métiers et les territoires.
C'est une politique
qui est si multifactorielle
qu'il ne faut pas juste centrer
sur : "On leur dit
qu'il ne faut pas aller là,
"mais ils peuvent aller là."
Ca ne dépend pas uniquement
de ce facteur-là.
-Dr Hamon, vous bouillez
depuis tout à l'heure,
-Je suis heureux
que M. Valletoux dise
qu'il est contre la coercition
mais ça n'a pas toujours
été son cas.
-On va essayer d'être constructif.
-Il aura du mal.
-Je peux parler du Danemark,
car j'y suis allé, justement.
Au Danemark, si un médecin veut
s'installer dans une région,
on lui dit : "C'est à tel endroit."
Mais dans la région.
Il choisit la région
où il veut s'installer.
Il ne travaille pas
dans les mêmes conditions
que le médecin français.
Si vous voulez permettre
aux jeunes de s'installer,
il faut qu'ils aient un secrétariat
présentiel, des locaux corrects
et faire découvrir aux internes
cette médecine
qui est passionnante à exercer.
La différence,
c'est que les médecins danois
collaborent avec l'hôpital :
ils vont régulièrement
à l'hôpital
et il y a une collaboration
avec l'hôpital,
tandis qu'ici,
il y a maintenant une concurrence
avec l'hôpital qui fait des choses
qui pourraient être faites en ville.
-Donc, c'est un système
qui vous paraît
plutôt positif ?
-Vous avez parlé du Danemark,
vous avez parlé
aussi de la Creuse.
Je suis allé à Royère-de-Vassivière,
un désert de population.
Mais à Royère-de-Vassivière,
les médecins ont fait venir
des internes,
les maires ont logé les internes,
il y a eu une prime
pour que les internes
puissent venir dans la Creuse.
Quand j'ai visité ce cabinet,
il y avait
quatre médecins
qui avaient deux collaborateurs,
d'anciens internes.
-C'est exemplaire, ça ?
-Ils étaient prêts à s'installer
car ils ont découvert
une médecine de 1er recours
passionnante à exercer,
pourvu qu'on donne
l'habitude aux internes
d'aller dans ces zones
dans de bonnes conditions.
Là, c'était le cas.
-Vous seriez allée dans la Creuse
si on vous avait promis
de bons collaborateurs ?
C'est aussi simple que ça ?
-Non.
Les futurs médecins généralistes
sont formés à l'hôpital,
dans un système universitaire,
pour toutes les problématiques
de main-d'oeuvre à l'hôpital,
d'internes qui vont aider.
C'est la problématique
des formations initiale et continue
à la sortie de l'internat.
Si on arrive
à revaloriser ce métier,
redonner du sens...
Les maîtres de stage sur le terrain
transmettent une passion.
Encore faut-il qu'elle existe.
Une fois qu'elle est transmise,
si elle arrive à être transmise...
Je pense que les gens ont envie
de faire du soin,
quel que soit l'endroit,
à condition,
comme le disait le Dr Hamon,
qu'ils puissent
y vivre confortablement,
qu'il y ait une attractivité
pour les conjoints.
C'est la répartition
sur le territoire qui compte
avec l'organisation par territoire.
-Pour bien comprendre
ce qu'est l'exercice de la médecine
aujourd'hui, et vous l'avez dit,
il ne suffit pas d'incitations,
il faut rendre
une attractivité au métier.
Beaucoup de jeunes médecins
cherchent un bon équilibre
pour ne pas avoir de burn-out.
Allons suivre
un médecin à Marseille,
un jeune médecin généraliste
qui a trouvé une solution
pour pouvoir combiner
son plaisir, sa vocation,
avec sa vie personnelle.
C'est un reportage
de Marianne Cazaux.
-Nager pendant sa journée
de travail,
c'est commun pour un athlète,
moins pour un médecin généraliste,
mais c'est le seul moyen
que Thierry Nieto a trouvé
pour relâcher
enfin la pression.
-Le Covid, notamment,
ça a été
très éprouvant physiquement
et surtout mentalement.
Depuis cette période-là,
je vois les choses différemment,
et je prends plus le temps
de décompresser,
de gérer les choses,
de mettre des limites,
ce que je faisais
peut-être pas.
-Une décision nécessaire
pour tenir le rythme,
car les journées du Dr Nieto
ressemblent souvent
à un numéro d'équilibriste.
Ouverture du cabinet à 8h45.
-Ce matin,
j'ai 12 consultations
qui sont prévues.
-Quelques minutes avant que le flot
ininterrompu des patients n'arrive.
-Bonjour, monsieur.
-Jeunes ou âgés,
en bonne santé ou souffrant
de plusieurs maladies chroniques,
les patients s'enchaînent.
-Alors voilà,
la prise de sang me contrôle.
On a dit la mammo.
La colo, on est bon.
Vous en êtes où niveau vaccination
Covid, grippe ?
-En tant que médecin traitant,
Thierry Nieto doit faire
de la prévention,
prendre le temps d'expliquer...
-Elle est nickel,
la tension : 107/59.
En langage courant, on dit 10/5.
-...et de rassurer les patients.
-Quand on manque beaucoup de fer,
on fait des anémies,
les globules rouges baissent
et a des symptômes : on est fatigué.
Ce n'est pas le cas.
Vous, c'est juste les réserves
en fer qui sont basses,
mais ça s'explique
par votre alimentation.
-Mais ce faisant, le temps file,
alors il faut gérer les priorités...
-Ca peut être intéressant
de faire la kiné,
rééducation du rachis lombaire.
-D'accord.
-Et après, on s'occupera
du problème hémato sans urgence.
Bonne journée.
-...ce qui est difficile à vivre
pour ce médecin très investi.
On est torturé entre essayer
de faire de la qualité,
si je veux faire de la qualité,
je garde tout le monde longtemps
et j'ai 2 heures de retard
et je rentre à 22h,
et essayer de faire
quelque chose de viable,
avec des temps
de consultation limités.
Souvent,
on est obligé d'être directif,
poser les questions qu'il faut
pour pouvoir
les soigner plus rapidement.
Oui, c'est ça qui est dommage,
en fait.
-Car aux consultations s'ajoutent
plus de 5 heures par semaine
de tâches administratives.
-Il n'y a plus rien qui marche.
-Thierry Nieto
s'y attelle
pendant sa pause déjeuner,
avant de commencer sa tournée
des visites à domicile.
Musique légère
-Du coup, vous toussez un peu.
-Elles sont essentielles
pour ces patients âgés
qui ne peuvent plus se déplacer
jusqu'au cabinet.
-Ils vous ont remis
un petit peu d'attaque.
-Les autres docteurs,
c'est très compliqué.
Il y en a qui ne veulent plus
venir à domicile.
C'est vrai, hein.
J'ai subi sept opérations,
quand même.
Deux de la colonne vertébrale,
deux du genou,
dans la prothèse,
et quatre de la hanche.
-Thierry Nieto se voit
comme un médecin de famille.
Il tient à ces moments privilégiés
avec des personnes qu'il suit
sur le long terme,
comme cette patiente
dont il a accompagné la mère
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours.
Mais il a décidé de ne plus prendre
de nouveaux patients
qui n'ont pas la capacité
de se rendre au cabinet,
car une visite n'est pas rentable
pour un médecin libéral.
Elle prend 3 à 4 fois plus de temps
qu'une consultation pour seulement
10 euros de plus.
Du coup, 35, s'il vous plaît.
-En faisant ce choix,
Thierry Nieto ne peut s'empêcher
de culpabiliser.
-On essaie de leur trouver
des solutions,
mais ils disent :
"Vous connaissez un confrère
"qui fait des visites à domicile ?"
Non, car la plupart sont
dans le même cas que moi.
Certains n'en font plus.
On fait quand même ce boulot
pour aider les gens,
pour les soigner
et pas pour refuser des soins.
Donc oui, c'est un vrai échec.
-Mais pour lui,
il n'y a
qu'avec cet équilibre fragile
qu'il peut tenir sur la durée.
Bip du tensiomètre
-Bon, c'est pas le seul métier
qui est sous stress,
on ne va pas non plus dramatiser,
mais quand même,
ce n'est pas un métier
comme les autres.
Vous aussi,
vous allez à la piscine,
Dr Crest ?
-Je fais du bateau, moi.
-C'est vital pour vous ?
Ce n'est pas qu'un loisir ?
-C'est l'équilibre de la vie,
quelle que soit la profession.
C'est un équilibre
vie privée-vie professionnelle,
sport-santé,
alimentation-santé,
sommeil, gestion des émotions.
Le métier du soin subit
des violences,
en particulier actuellement,
des violences par le métier
qui est difficile,
les institutions qui mettent
la pression sur les généralistes,
comme si le médecin, en fait,
était la cause des problématiques
du vieillissement de la population,
du mal-être de la société.
Toutes ces pressions font
qu'il a besoin
de prendre soin de lui.
En fait, si le médecin
ne va pas bien, ou l'infirmière,
demain, il n'y aura plus personne
pour s'occuper des gens.
-Les jeunes médecins
ne veulent pas travailler
comme vous avez travaillé.
50 heures par semaine,
c'est fini, hein ?
-C'est normal,
parce que les 35 heures
sont passées par là.
Quand je me suis arrivé,
quand je me suis installé,
on avait encore l'image
du médecin généraliste
qui était taillable et corvéable
à merci, qui se levait la nuit.
Les médecins
que j'ai remplacés travaillaient
dans une grande maison, avaient du
personnel à la maison.
-On ne va pas pleurer
sur le lait renversé.
C'est fini.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
-Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
On permet aux médecins
de travailler ensemble.
Je milite pour des groupes
monodisciplinaires.
Je peux vous dire qu'on est
5 médecins généralistes
et il faudra qu'on soit 6 ou 7
pour assurer la continuité
des soins.
Il faut les moyens
d'avoir un secrétariat,
il faut pouvoir le payer,
C'est ça qui nous décharge
des tâches administratives.
C'est ça qui nous permet de faire
des visites à domicile
chez les personnes
qui ne peuvent plus se déplacer.
Ca aussi, on parle
du vieillissement de la population,
mais on ne peut maintenir
les gens à domicile
qu'avec des infirmiers
et des kinés
qui puissent se déplacer.
Or, les infirmiers
se déplacent pour 2,50 euros,
2,75 euros, M. Braun a tweeté
qu'il avait augmenté de 10 %
le déplacement des infirmiers,
2,75 euros,
2,50 euros pour le kiné.
C'est des professions capitales.
-Le salariat...
Arnaud Bontemps,
qu'on n'a pas entendu.
Est-ce que le salariat,
dans les centres de santé,
est un bon moyen d'attirer
des médecins
dans les déserts médicaux ?
Ce qu'on constate,
c'est que le paiement à l'acte
met les professionnels de santé
dans un système
d'injonctions contradictoires.
Le médecin qu'on voit là
nous parle de qualité,
nous dit :
"J'ai pas le temps."
Tout temps de coordination,
toute réunion qu'il va faire
avec une infirmière
sera du temps où il ne sera pas
payé en consultation,
qui sera un manque à gagner.
C'est une injonction contradictoire
contenue dans le système,
ce n'est pas la faute
à Paul ou Jacques,
mais on doit repenser
ce système monoprofessionnel,
c'est ce qu'a dit Jean-Paul Hamon,
à l'envers : je pense
qu'on n'en sortira pas
si on ne considère que les médecins.
On a besoin de considérer
toutes les professions
qui sont autour.
On a besoin de penser autre chose
que le paiement à l'acte.
Le salariat dans les centres
de santé le permet.
Si le salariat est un modèle,
il est de plus en plus attractif
pour les médecins,
c'est parce qu'il y a
une meilleure conciliation
entre équilibre pro
et vie personnelle,
c'est parce qu'il y a
un environnement pluriprofessionnel,
une capacité à mieux prendre
en soin les patients.
-C'est intéressant,
ce que vous dites,
mais factuellement,
est-ce que ça aide,
le salariat,
à attirer les médecins ?
Nous, ce qu'on a observé
en tant que patient,
c'est que l'exercice groupé,
que ce soit en maisons
pluriprofessionnelles
ou en maisons
de santé publiques salariées,
c'est apprécié
à la fois par les patients
et par les professionnels.
Effectivement,
si le médecin d'aujourd'hui
veut travailler 35 heures
mais qu'il est déchargé complètement
des tâches administratives,
ça permet de limiter les dégâts
sur le nombre d'heures à effectuer,
vraiment, des actes.
-Ma question, c'est :
si on salarie les médecins,
une collectivité, par exemple,
est-ce que ça permet
d'attirer plus de médecins ?
Est-ce efficace
en termes de réponse
à la demande de soins ?
-Plusieurs choses.
On a autorisé les collectivités
à salarier des médecins.
Février 2022, je crois.
On en est aux balbutiements.
-On n'a pas encore de recul ?
-Si, si.
Ca se faisait, avant,
mais illégalement, il me semble.
-Frédéric Valletoux.
-Ca se faisait, enfin,
il y a eu des expérimentations
qui ont été faites.
Mais ça se fait,
et on voit qu'effectivement,
les médecins sont...
-Oui.
-On a suffisamment de recul.
Ca marche.
-Effectivement.
Vous démarrez votre journée,
que vous voyiez un patient
ou vous soyez en réunion
de coordination,
vous serez payé
puisque vous connaissez
le revenu que vous aurez.
Ca n'incite pas forcément
à y consacrer plus de temps
que le temps qui est
dans le contrat
que vous avez signé.
C'est un autre modèle
que le modèle libéral,
mais on voit
que c'est un modèle
qui intéresse beaucoup les jeunes.
Il faut voir que,
dans cette crise qu'on vit
du médecin de famille,
puisque c'est le thème
de l'émission,
c'est aussi que,
pendant longtemps,
la médecine générale a été
profondément déconsidérée
dans les études de médecine
et par les jeunes médecins.
Ceux qui faisaient
médecins généralistes...
-Il y avait le spécialiste
et le généraliste.
-On a préféré les spécialistes.
Le généraliste
était pas capable
de faire chirurgie.
-C'est toujours le cas ?
Est-ce que c'est
toujours considéré...
Dites-moi.
-Je ne pense pas.
La médecine générale est reconnue
comme étant une spécialité.
Donc il y a, voilà,
et il y a de plus
en plus de médecins généraux
qui travaillent avec des hôpitaux,
dans des programmes de recherche,
il y a une dimension
universitaire qui peut
continuer à rester.
Beaucoup de cabinets
peuvent former
de jeunes internes.
Ca évolue.
La médecine générale d'équipe
permet de structurer
des cabinets qui accueillent
de jeunes internes au rôle
d'accompagnement
des jeunes générations.
-Le salariat, ça répond
à des besoins
sur certains territoires.
Pas question de généraliser
comme en Grande-Bretagne,
on n'en est pas là.
Là, il y a ce salariat.
Je voudrais qu'on s'arrête
sur quelque chose
qui se développe dans la pratique,
pour le patient
et pour le médecin,
c'est la télémédecine.
Regardez ce reportage.
-Et si votre nouveau médecin
tenait dans cette cabine ?
Stéthoscope connecté, thermomètre,
prise de tension automatique :
un dispositif digne des astronautes.
Pourtant, nous sommes
dans une petite commune
de l'Essonne
tout ce qu'il y a de plus normale.
Une cabine de téléconsultation
a été installée pour assurer
la continuité des soins
dans cette zone sous-dotée.
-Je vais vous demander
de vous désinfecter les mains.
-Ici, pas de personnel médical.
L'accueil est assuré
par un employé de la mairie.
-Mon médecin n'est pas toujours
disponible pour me prendre.
Il est à 25 kilomètres de chez moi.
J'ai été loin parce que j'avais
mon médecin sur Mennecy,
mais il est parti à la retraite.
Après, j'ai eu du mal
à en trouver un.
*-Bonjour et bienvenue.
Veuillez insérer votre carte Vitale
dans le lecteur situé face à vous.
-Vous êtes connectée.
Je vous laisse.
-En fait le médecin, c'est lui,
mais il est à des centaines
de kilomètres.
*-Je suis le médecin téléconsultant.
-Bonjour, docteur.
*-Qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour vous ?
-J'ai de la tension.
*-On peut
utiliser certains outils
pour observer votre tension
et d'autres choses si besoin.
-Les instruments médicaux
doivent être manipulés
par le patient lui-même,
et ce n'est pas toujours
si facile.
*-Si vous n'êtes pas à l'aise,
votre bras est
n'est peut-être pas assez appliqué
ou en tout cas posé
le long du dispositif.
Ca nécessite
une manip, au départ.
Ca me paraît bien.
-Les données sont reçues en temps
réel sur l'ordinateur du médecin.
Le patient devient
son propre infirmier,
suivant les directives
du docteur.
*-Vous mettez votre index
collé contre la clavicule, en haut.
-Ecoute du coeur,
prise de température...
Le conduit auditif et même
la gorge peuvent être auscultés.
*-Vous allez tirer la langue
et faites "ah".
*-Ah.
*-Eh ben voilà,
parfait, on a tout.
C'est bon pour moi,
la gorge est saine, pas de soucis.
Je rédige un compte rendu
pour votre médecin traitant,
il va sortir devant vous.
Vous allez avoir
quelques petits instants d'attente.
-Un simple compte rendu.
Le rôle de surveillance est laissé
au médecin traitant.
*-C'est du 1er recours.
C'est une consultation
plutôt au contexte,
comme SOS Médecins
ou peut-être les urgences,
où le patient prend un rendez-vous
et tombe sur un médecin
qui sera celui dispo au moment venu,
mais pas celui
qu'il aura choisi.
Vous voyez votre médecin
la semaine prochaine.
On voit comment ça peut s'améliorer.
-La télémédecine ne s'adresse pas
qu'aux consultations d'urgence.
Parmi les applications
qui se sont développées,
certaines se sont spécialisées
dans le télé-suivi des patients
souffrant de maladies chroniques,
comme Nicole,
insuffisante cardiaque.
A 78 ans,
elle se connecte régulièrement.
Ainsi, tous les lundis,
c'est la même routine.
-Alors là, c'était 45/600,
ce matin.
Est-ce que je tousse ?
Pas du tout.
"Terminer".
Voilà.
Ca me permet de voir
l'évolution de ma maladie
et de gérer un peu,
de savoir où j'en suis.
C'est rassurant
parce qu'on se sent pas
tout seul.
-Mais pas de chance, ce jour-là,
Nicole réalise
qu'elle vient de se tromper
dans l'une de ses réponses.
-J'ai mis 45/800,
et c'est 46/800 et 46/600.
-Ce n'est pas possible
de revenir en arrière ?
-J'essaie,
mais ça ne marche pas.
"Contactez-nous",
ils nous disent,
mais je ne sais pas
qui je dois contacte.
-Alors, elle l'admet :
avec le numérique,
il lui manque quand même
un peu de contact humain.
-Dans les questions,
on demande de répondre
presque par oui ou par non.
Il n'y a pas de dialogue possible,
quoi, c'est ça.
-Avec la télémédecine,
la prise en main
n'est pas toujours simple.
Pour les patients,
l'accompagnement d'un médecin
reste essentiel.
-Il est essentiel,
mais Dr Hamon, si j'ai besoin
d'un renouvellement d'ordonnance,
je veux bien aller en cabine
pour pas encombrer
vos cabinets.
-Un renouvellement
d'ordonnance n'est jamais
que ça.
C'est une réévaluation
du traitement.
Entendre parler
de renouvellement...
Un renouvellement d'ordonnance,
c'est une consultation.
Vous pesez les gens,
vous leur prenez la tension.
-Ca, c'est l'idéal.
Mais au lieu d'attendre
pendant 6 mois un rendez-vous,
si je vais dans ma cabine
et que j'ai un contact à distance
avec un médecin...
-La téléconsultation est bien
quand elle est utilisée
par un médecin qui prend contact
avec un infirmier au domicile
du patient pour avoir une expertise.
-Avec un infirmier à côté ?
-C'est un bon outil
quand on demande un avis
à un médecin spécialiste,
et là, il y a une expertise.
Là, c'est une dégradation
de la qualité
de prise en charge des patients,
parce que l'Etat depuis 20 ans,
refuse...
-Vous êtes tous d'accord ?
-Il refuse de redonner
de l'attractivité à ce métier.
-On ne va pas y revenir.
-L'exemple de la Saône-et-Loire.
La Saône-et-Loire a salarié
84 médecins.
Vous savez
quel est le rendement de ces gens
qui sont payés entre 5000
et 6000 euros par an par mois ?
27 consultations par semaine,
27 consultations par semaine.
-On peut aller vérifier ?
-Oui, 300 millions
de recettes pour 84 médecins.
-Etes-vous tous d'accord
pour revenir
sur la téléconsultation ?
Est-ce un contre-modèle ?
Ou est-ce que...
Il y a un chiffre
qui m'a frappée.
80 000 téléconsultations
en 2019,
avant le Covid, bien sûr.
9,4 millions
en 2021.
-7 sur 10 en zone urbaine.
-Et alors, quelles conclusions ?
-Quelles conclusions ?
La télémédecine, c'est un outil
qui s'adresse à des patientèles,
c'est une étude de la DREES,
qui sont jeunes, connectées,
et donc qui ont
moins de problèmes de santé
et qui sont plus à l'aise
avec le numérique.
A priori, c'est peut-être
un petit peu mieux.
En revanche, pour aller
vers l'accompagnement
des personnes qui sont
en pathologies chroniques,
il faut du lien humain
et on a besoin de sortir du modèle
du seul médecin traitant
qui fait tout,
On a besoin de délégations d'actes,
de travail en équipe,
de travail avec des infirmiers.
-Zéro coordination.
-C'est important,
on ne l'a pas encore évoqué,
mais une des voies d'avenir,
c'est de sortir du mythe
du médecin qui peut tout faire
et qui travaille beaucoup plus
en équipe
en acceptant de faire
monter en responsabilités...
-Attendez, mais...
De quelle tâche doit-il
se décharger,
ce médecin qui fait tout ?
-Les infirmières
en pratique avancée,
c'est une voie qui permet,
aux côtés du médecin
et sous sa responsabilité,
de pouvoir, effectivement,
confier des responsabilités
à des infirmières
qui sont formées pour ça.
-C'est votre proposition de loi ?
-C'est dans une autre...
-Des certificats
pour enfants malades
peuvent être remplacés...
-Le Sénat l'a rajouté.
-...par des déclarations
sur l'honneur. Intéressant.
Vous êtes d'accord ?
-Alors,
tout ce qui est
tâches administratives,
les certificats, etc.,
il faut absolument
revenir là-dessus,
c'est une perte de temps,
par contre,
si la médecine de demain,
c'est la téléconsultation,
moi, j'arrête mon métier,
j'ai besoin de toucher les gens.
-Vous les verrez,
vous aurez toujours des patients.
-Ce sera pas pareil.
C'est une perte de sens
sur le métier.
Par contre, le patient a
un rôle-clé à jouer,
et on ne parle pas de prévention.
On n'est pas très bons,
en France, par rapport à ça.
Beaucoup de téléconsultations
sont pour des réponses d'anxiété,
de manque de formation
et d'éducation en santé
de la population,
c'est-à-dire
que les gens sont anxieux,
surtout depuis le Covid,
ils ont besoin d'être
encore plus assistés, écoutés
et accompagnés.
Ca tombe sur le médecin traitant.
En termes de prévention,
il y a du travail à faire.
On pourrait limiter l'accès...
Bien sûr !
Tout ce qui est prévention santé,
alimentation, sport,
ça a un impact pas forcément
à l'instant T, mais à l'instant T+1,
sur les maladies chroniques.
-Si je comprends bien,
pour résumer, mais corrigez-moi,
la prévention,
c'est si important
que vous délégueriez des tâches,
comme le certificat médical
au début de l'année...
-De toute façon,
il n'a pas de valeur juridique.
-Et les vaccins ?
-La délégation doit se faire
de manière bilatérale
et coordonnée.
Il y a des tâches
qui sont à déléguer à d'autres.
-Afin de faire de la prévention.
-Chaque fois qu'on a voulu faire ça,
il y a eu des batailles sans fin,
comme celle pour que
les pharmaciens puissent vacciner,
contre les syndicats de médecins,
qui étaient contre.
Les infirmières de pratique avancée
bataillent
contre les syndicats de médecins.
A chaque fois
qu'on a eu la volonté de dire :
"On va essayer d'organiser
"des équipes de soin
autour du médecin..."
Il s'agit pas de marginaliser
le médecin...
-Et pourtant,
ça permet de faire
de la meilleure qualité.
Dans un centre de santé
où je suis bénévole,
il y a une infirmière
de pratique avancée
aux côtés de médecins,
elle a des consultations d'une heure
avec ses patients diabétiques.
La qualité est incommensurable.
Le suivi des patients...
C'est de la délégation efficace,
avec le médecin
dans le bureau d'à côté...
-C'est grâce à quoi ?
Grâce à quoi ça existe ?
-La délégation et les structures
pluriprofessionnelles,
avec des professionnels
qui travaillent ensemble.
-On va explorer...
-Pour généraliser,
imaginez le coût
de ce que vous présentez là !
J'ai une infirmière
en pratique avancée
qui prend une heure
avec un patient.
Formidable,
mais qui la paye, et combien ?
Quels locaux vous avez ?
-Docteur,
voici un autre modèle.
C'est assez frappant.
On va retourner
dans la Creuse, pardon.
C'est un des départements concernés
par notre sujet, à Ajain.
Là,
les médecins ne sont pas regroupés,
les médecins se succèdent,
et ils font des missions
d'une semaine,
et c'est à cette condition-là
qu'on arrive à avoir
un médecin devant les patients.
Reportage Marianne Cazaux.
-C'est peut-être difficile à croire,
mais il est parfois plus facile
de trouver 50 médecins qu'un seul.
Dans le village d'Ajain,
dans la Creuse, chaque semaine,
les généralistes se suivent
et ne se ressemblent pas.
-C'est une dame,
le médecin, aujourd'hui.
C'est une dame.
Elle est très gentille.
-Sous le regard des coordinatrices,
les praticiens
se relaient
pour assurer l'accès aux soins
des habitants de ce désert médical.
1200 patients
ont choisi ce centre de santé
comme médecin traitant.
-Centre médical d'Ajain, bonjour ?
Je vous mets avec un autre patient,
mais comme c'est une urgence...
Quand il y a eu
une proposition de poste
de publiée,
je me suis demandé
ce que c'était.
C'était assez curieux.
On se lance là-dedans,
parce qu'on se dit
qu'on est dans une aventure
où on est là pour aider,
pour trouver des solutions, surtout,
de pas juste rester
en se disant "on n'a rien".
-Plus de 200 généralistes
se sont eux aussi engagés
dans le projet du collectif
des Médecins Solidaires.
Le planning des remplacements
est plein jusqu'en janvier 2024.
Pour chaque médecin,
transport et logement
sont pris en charge.
La rémunération est
de 1000 euros net pour 35 heures.
ce n'est pas l'aspect financier
qui a poussé ce médecin
à venir assurer les consultations
cette semaine.
-Quand on voit
des patients, comme ce matin,
qui n'avaient pas consulté
depuis plus de 2-3 ans...
Notre métier,
c'est quand même d'aider.
D'aider l'autre.
Donc...
Oui...
Je me sens plus utile ici
qu'en région parisienne,
où j'ai aussi exercé.
-Retraités encore actifs,
comme elle,
ou jeunes pas encore installés,
les médecins doivent assurer
la continuité des soins.
La bonne tenue des dossiers médicaux
est essentielle.
-Si vous permettez,
on se connaît pas,
donc je vais faire un tour rapide
de votre dossier
pour me mettre un petit peu
dans l'affaire.
Vous êtes suivi
pour de l'hypertension,
problème de thyroïde,
un diabète, et vous faites
des apnées du sommeil, c'est ça ?
-J'ai besoin de voir
tous les trois mois
un médecin qui soit au courant
de mon dossier
et qui puisse me renouveler
mon traitement
et voir, éventuellement,
si d'autres problèmes
sont survenus.
-L'ouverture du centre a été
un soulagement,
deux ans
après le départ à la retraite
du médecin du village.
Les habitants désespéraient
d'en trouver un nouveau.
-J'avais arrêté le traitement.
J'en avais marre.
Que je crève d'un côté
ou de l'autre...
Heureusement, ils sont arrivés.
Il m'a dit :
"Non, non, il faut pas...
"Il faut pas déconner avec ça.
"On va vous prendre en main."
-Une personne qui tombe en panne,
elle regarde pas
qui va venir la dépanner.
Moi, je pars de ce principe.
Que je sois soigné
par un médecin traitant
toute l'année
et que ce soit le même,
ou 50, ça me dérange pas.
Du moment qu'on prend le téléphone,
qu'on les appelle, on a un souci...
Après, si c'est un annuel
ou un semaine,
c'est pas grave.
-Avant de trouver cette solution,
la commune avait tout essayé.
Elle a réalisé
une vidéo promotionnelle
à laquelle les commerçants,
comme Gilles, ont participé.
*-...un bureau de tabac.
Le seul problème,
c'est que notre docteur,
qui est là depuis 40 ans,
part à la retraite
à la fin de l'année.
-Des situations comme celle-ci,
le Dr Martial Jardel
en a rencontré beaucoup.
Fraîchement diplômé, à 30 ans,
il a fait un tour de France
des remplacements
dans des déserts médicaux.
Aujourd'hui installé,
il comprend très bien pourquoi
cette décision est difficile
à prendre.
-Quand on a 30 ans et qu'on se dit
que si on change de projet de vie,
on crée un drame humain,
on n'a pas envie
de créer un drame humain,
donc on préfère ne pas s'installer.
Donc, plus il y a de pénurie,
plus ça entraîne de la pénurie.
Les médecins ont peur de s'installer
dans des territoires
où c'est uniquement eux
qui tiendront
la responsabilité
de l'accès aux soins.
Donc, partager
cette responsabilité-là,
c'est un élément de réponse.
On leur dit :
"Vous n'allez pas être responsables
"d'un accès aux soins pour 30 ans,
mais vous allez être responsables
"d'un accès aux soins
pour une semaine."
-C'est ainsi qu'il a eu l'idée
de fonder le collectif
des Médecins Solidaires.
Aujourd'hui,
200 généralistes font partie
du réseau
pour s'essayer à la médecine rurale.
A la fin de son remplacement,
le médecin recevra un panier garni.
-Une nonette à la myrtille,
de la terrine...
-De quelques-uns des meilleurs
arguments de la région,
pour qu'un médecin de passage
s'y installe.
-J'ai bien aimé la première phrase
de ce reportage : "C'est plus facile
"d'en trouver 50 qu'un seul."
Bon,
c'est pas l'idéal, évidemment,
mais est-ce une solution
pour les déserts médicaux,
cette tribu de médecins
qui se passent la main ?
-C'est mieux que rien.
On est dans une gestion
de la pénurie.
Après, en termes de suivi,
c'est moins bien
que d'avoir un suivi dans la durée,
sachant qu'avec Mon espace santé,
le fait de centraliser
tous les documents,
les résultats d'analyses et autres
sur une plate-forme,
ça pourrait améliorer le suivi,
faute de mieux.
Après, ce serait mieux d'avoir
un système qui favorise
les installations pérennes,
mais voilà,
si ce n'est pas possible,
il vaut mieux ça que rien.
-Il y a de l'imagination dans l'air.
On cherche des solutions
pour essayer de mettre
des médecins devant des patients.
Si vous aviez une mesure,
Dr Crest,
que vous voudriez voir aujourd'hui
mise en oeuvre
pour y répondre ? Il y a 20 façons
d'aborder la question,
la question tarifaire,
la rémunération, l'attractivité...
Pour vous, le plus important ?
-C'est tellement complexe
que je peux pas vous dire
une chose comme ça.
Dans tous ces conflits,
c'est toujours bilatéral.
Il y a un besoin
d'écouter et de comprendre.
Pourquoi les syndicats de médecins
ont-ils peur
de la délégation de tâches ?
Il y a un problème de reconnaissance
et de respect mutuel,
que ce soit
avec les rendez-vous non honorés,
que ce soit la qualité
des consultations...
-Il y en a beaucoup de non honorés ?
-28 millions par an.
-Non, mais pour vous ?
-Moi, j'essaie d'avoir
une autorité douce sur mes patients
et de leur expliquer
pourquoi ça me crée du tort
et ça me fait même du mal,
d'avoir du temps
où je pourrais accueillir quelqu'un,
et que ce temps soit perdu.
-Si j'ai un rendez-vous
et que je ne viens pas,
vous ne me reprenez pas ?
-La 1re fois, non,
mais la 2e, je vous explique.
Je crois dans l'éducation.
Les gens doivent comprendre.
Sinon, ça ne marchera pas.
Des deux côtés,
il y a une souffrance.
Si on n'essaye pas de la comprendre,
au sens compréhension sociétale,
psychologique,
on n'y arrivera pas.
Je suis vraiment
pour ce modèle-là d'écoute,
vraiment,
parce que sinon, on n'avancera pas.
-Et on rappelle
que vous présentez votre rapport
en décembre
sur l'amélioration
de la santé des soignants.
Ils soignent,
mais doivent être soignés.
Arnaud Bontemps ?
-On a un enjeu de réponse
aux maladies chroniques
qui se développent,
à l'enjeu de la qualité de travail
des professionnels,
et ils sont pris dans
des injonctions contradictoires,
notamment à cause
du modèle de rémunération.
Il faudrait qu'on ait le courage
de s'attaquer à ça.
Les négociations...
Il y a pas si longtemps,
on a eu une grève
de certains professionnels de santé,
concentrée autour du tarif
de la consultation.
Le tarif de la tâche.
Il faut qu'on sorte...
-26,50 euros.
-26,50,
30...
On entendait 50...
Ce n'est pas la bonne question.
La question, c'est :
"comment on a un modèle
qui permet la coordination,
"la prise en soin
des patients complexes,
"le travail en équipe ?"
On a besoin de sortir
du paiement à la tâche.
Tout le monde s'en sortira grandi.
Les patients auront
une meilleure qualité de soins,
les professionnels, de travail.
Le système de santé aura
plus de temps pour la prévention
et pourra avancer dans le défi
des maladies chroniques.
-Dr Hamon, une mesure ?
-Des moyens
pour éviter les hospitalisations,
s'appuyer sur les équipes
de soins primaires,
supprimer les prestataires
qui bouffent la laine
sur le dos des pharmaciens
et des infirmières,
et ça leur donnera envie
de pas changer de métier,
faire en sorte que...
Les moyens, on les a.
J'ai appris que l'Etat avait piqué
8 milliards dans la Cades,
qui est un impôt
qui rapporte 23 milliards.
8 milliards depuis trois ans
pour investir à l'hôpital.
Qu'on investisse ces 8 milliards
pour la ville...
-Trop de mesures
tue la mesure...
-Il faut les moyens...
-Il faut se présenter aux élections.
-Et pas des rustines,
comme M. Valletoux !
-Présentez-vous aux élections.
-Euh, pardon.
-Ca va venir.
On va peut-être faire
des listes européennes.
-La parole à votre voisine.
-Réguler l'installation,
comme ce qui se fait
pour les pharmaciens,
comme ça se fait pour les dentistes,
pour les infirmières, les kinés...
Il ne reste que les médecins
pour lesquels ce n'est pas régulé.
Vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que les vocations baissaient.
De mémoire,
à la dernière promo,
60 % des étudiants
qui ont validé leur 1re année
n'ont pas été admis en 2e année.
Je ne vois pas
les vocations en baisse.
Il faut réguler l'installation,
et augmenter les capacités
des facs de médecine.
-Frédéric Valletoux ?
-Moi, je crois profondément
en la capacité des soignants
à inventer des prises en charge
différentes
d'un territoire à l'autre.
Il faut arriver à décloisonner
et à sortir de ce face-à-face
entre médecine hospitalière
et libérale,
le généraliste et le spécialiste,
le médecin et l'infirmière, etc.,
pour arriver
à ce que ce soit plus fluide,
et il faut leur faire confiance
et il faut qu'on sorte
d'un système,
qu'on fasse plus confiance
aux initiatives de terrain,
aux prises en charge
qui soient décidées
par les soignants,
c'est-à-dire
qu'on soit moins prescriptif
au niveau national,
un système très jacobin,
très encadré...
-Laisser l'initiative au terrain ?
-C'est ce que ma proposition de loi
essayait de faire
pour faire porter
une nouvelle étape.
-Pour conclure
sur une note pas trop grave,
Guérir en Mer
accompagne les soignants
qui sont victimes de burn-out.
Ca consiste en quoi ?
-C'est de la prévention
et de l'accompagnement
de l'épuisement,
toutes professions
du soin confondues.
On décloisonne.
-Et vous faites quoi ?
-On va faire du bateau.
Le bateau est
un sport santé incroyable.
Les parallèles entre la voile
et la santé sont énormes :
gestion des émotions,
travail en équipe,
et aussi solitude intense,
sport, environnement naturel,
travail d'équipe...
Quand on est soignant,
on s'adapte sur un bateau.
On peut s'inspirer
de ce qui se passe en mer
pour le milieu professionnel.
Ca crée du lien
entre les soignants
qui manquent de communication
entre eux.
Ca revalorise. On a une tâche,
on peut la faire. Sur un bateau,
on peut pas jeter à la mer
quelqu'un, on avance ensemble.
-Alors, évidemment,
en Creuse,
il y a des rivières.
-Ca marche aussi.
-Il y a aussi des lacs.
Le lac de Vassivière.
Merci infiniment,
et j'imagine
qu'on peut trouver l'association,
si on est au bord
d'un littoral,
sur Internet...
Merci beaucoup, Dr Crest.
Merci infiniment, Arnaud Bontemps.
Merci, Frédéric Valletoux,
Mme Roubtsova et Dr Hamon,
toujours aussi passionné.
C'est la fin de cet "Etat de santé"
consacré aux médecins généralistes.
A très vite et à bientôt sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...